sherry's off today is your most accurate
weather now forecast we start with our
camera on top of the bank of america and
you see the flags whipping
and there are some raindrops falling in
parts of town you saw hector
here with his hood on officially we're
at 51 degrees
but hanging on to 60 in the strip upper
40 summerlin
a cold front is passing through that's
why we call it fro
paw that's meteorological shorthand for
frontal passage
and scattered showers we're not talking
about big time accumulation now later
this afternoon
could be a chance for a thunderstorm if
we get the sun heating up just a little
bit
speaking of heating up we go to nevada
and beyond still
66 in death valley part of a wind
advisory in fact there are three
different wind advisories none of them
including the las vegas metro area over
the hump and prep your starts at eight
o'clock this morning
this one and in southern california
starts at 11. there's one for boulder
city and the colorado river all the way
down towards laughlin that starts at 3
p.m
there will not be a quiz on this because
the bottom line is
it's just going to be windy all day
today
all night tonight and most of the day
tomorrow you've got some snow showers up
in alien 24 cedar you got some snow
showers and 30.
good morning to kingman with a 48. so
hour by hour at eight o'clock we'll try
for 54 with clouds and wind maybe some
storm clouds at noon and 60
a possibility some thunder along with
the wind and 64 at three
that's the forecast high temperature and
then maybe
a 62 at six o'clock still very windy
so your weather headlines all of the
wind advisories do not include las vegas
widely scattered showers and
thunderstorms our eight day forecast
coming up with
temperatures reaching 80 by next week
so for today we'll go for 64 where the
normal high would be 72
i don't think it's going to feel like 64
with all of the cloud cover
and most definitely all of that wind
there's that junior weather buddy talk
we got
fro paw or frontal passage right through
southern nevada during the day today so
we got wind ahead of it
we're going to have very strong wind
behind it as well checking on your
family and friends
the system we had over the weekend
that's turning into strong showers and
thunderstorms from the dakotas
all the way down to mississippi here's
your eight day forecast we'll go back to
68 with the wind continuing
70 and breezy on thursday a dip back to
the upper 60s and then we start climbing
back up
we are looking at a possibility of 80 by
monday but i think bianca most folks now
are concerned
about the wind and there may be some wet
roads out there too